this conference will take place in the
margins of the justice and Home Affairs
Council it will focus on the important
increase in the number of migrants
coming from the middle east through the
Western Balkans world it will aim to
enhance the engagement among your
partners increase in solidarity and also
ensuring an orderly management of the
refugee and migrant flows there will be
some key areas of discussion there will
be a discussion on how to increase
support to Jordan Lebanon and Turkey
which are the first countries of asylum
then there will be a discussion on how
to support all the affected transit
countries how they can improve reception
registration and Asylum procedures and
the third one will be enhancing the
cooperation to fight organized crime
were responsible for the migrant
smuggling and in trafficking in human
beings the high-level conference aims
also to engage with the countries of
origin of irregular migrants and also to
address the root causes of the forced
displacement